bonsoir bienvenue au café picouly une
nouvelle émission littéraire conçu pour
vous faire passer un moment agréable
dans un cadre inhabituel
alors qu'est ce qu'on va découvrir ce
soir dans cette émission est bien placé
au menu tout d'abord honneur aux anciens
vous savez que cette année 2005 et
l'année du centenaire de la mort de
jules verne alors nous vous offrons un
duel entre l'académicien orsenna et
l'historien mauduit virginie despentes
oui virginie despentes cbs mois bye bye
blondie
mais ce soir virginie despentes a décidé
de nous donner un cours de littérature
et sur quoi sur dust et husky andrea
coolio andrea coolio c'est un homme qui
est devenue une femme et qui va nous
raconter comment il a vécu la lecture de
ce chef-d'oeuvre absolu qu'est la
métamorphose de franz kafka un duel un
vrai cette fois ci rufin contre eysines
jean louis ezine c'est le chroniqueur
littéraire du nord
observateur qui a fait un papier
complètement assassin sur le dernier
livre de jean christophe rufin la
salamandre
bien évidemment nous allons donner
l'occasion à jean christophe rufin de
répondre à jean louis ezine beyala calix
l'africaine qui a accepté de siéger les
lecteurs de son nouveau roman la
plantation beigbeder beigbeder va parler
de lui vous allez me dire comme
d'habitude et bien non justement il a
parlé cette fois ci de lui de façon plus
intime et je trouve beaucoup plus
touchant elle vous ne la connaissais pas
c'est sonia moumen sonia moumen c'est un
premier roman et c'est une première
télévision signer comme on dit souvent
première télévision premier rendez-vous
premier amour
on s'en rappelle toujours eh bien on le
souhaite à sonia moumen et franchement
regardez belle ardoise non
non
[Musique]
échec et mat et une séquence qui va
permettre à deux de nos invités de
confronter leurs points de vue sur une
oeuvre ou sur un auteur aujourd'hui
jules verne nos deux invités roger
mauduit historiens des plus grands
spécialistes de la tradition orale en
france vous traitez les personnages
généralement sous l'angle de la
mythologie est quasiment est votre
prochaine ouvrage de croix c'est michel
fourniret un serial killer donc j'allais
dire un serial rêveur comme jules verne
ne pouvait pas vous laisser indifférent
et vous publiez
donc ce jules verne la face cachée c'est
à dire que vous reconnaissez les talents
de l'écrivain mais vous débusquer
l'homme est il ya ivoire erik orsenna on
connaît erik orsenna plus jeune membre
de l'académie française est le benjamin
or les camps pétillon et malicieuse qui
est rare à l'académie française
bientôt les troupes et vous verrez quand
vous entrerez prix goncourt 1987 avec
l'exposition coloniale
on connaît votre goût pour les mots
depuis la grammaire est une chanson
douce 500000 exemplaires traduit dans 15
langues
et cette fois-ci vous nous proposez un
portrait du gulf stream loges des
courants et dans ce texte
or s'énerve pose une question quasiment
métaphysique à savoir mais où commence
dont les gulfstream et comme
le capitaine nemo se demandait où ça
passe tout ça voilà où ça passe tout
s'arrête comment ce parce que les
voyages le golf s'il est une question
métaphysique à lui tout seul d'ailleurs
vous contentez pas comme lead in de
parler de ce courant vous allez y voir
un peu comme jules verne est allé alors
le maelström dans ce chan meurtrier de
la mer de norvège
et on voit là le côté aventureux là je
sens que jules absolument alors on va
vous regardez vous confronter sur jules
verne et voir si vous êtes aussi proches
l'un de l'autre que vous le semble hélas
en ce moment ça m'inquiète un peu de
voir si d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui vous a fait découvrir jules verne ça
doit être un mélange de mon papa et ma
maman
guy de maupassant à quel âge disons haut
et environ deux ou trois ans mais je le
vern l'intrigué des jeunes des jeunes
julien vous at il incité à voyager g22
personnes qui m'ont dit que il fallait
voyager c'est jules verne et crj avec
tata peut-être pas noir je pense qu'il
n'assistait pas mort de gens à voyager
que vous at il inspiré qu'il faut aller
voir de l'autre côté de ce convoi il
m'inspire des sentiments contradictoires
parfois un peu de rejet parfois beaucoup
d'amour et il influencé votre vie
totalement
je crois qu'il influence toujours je m
écriture oui pour le goût que j'ai des
accumulations oui pour aussi l'idée que
chaque histoire est un secret à
découvrir
on croit pas le méprise au soufre et
jules verne était il justifié
bien sûr que non il a été méprisée et
s'entend après il existe donc messieurs
les méprisants horizon merde
il n'a pas compris quelle était sa place
vouloir aller à l'académie française
c'était pas ça c'était vraiment pas sa
place d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
qui se souvient le qui était
académiciens au temps de jules verne une
invention que vous aimeriez montrer à
jules verne internote une voile qui
capterait les courants c'est à dire une
voile sous marine au fait connaissez
vous une citation de jules verne
oui c'est à dire les français pour jules
verne sont de preuves vous allez y mais
des cul de plomb fermez les guillemets
non monsieur ne pas un écrivain citation
le roman de jules verne le plus réussi
c'est l'ensemble on peut pas dire un
fleuve quel est votre mail est cubes
dont vous êtes le plus fier je dirais
vingt mille lieues sous les mers
une invention du jules verne que vous
préférez je le veux contrairement à une
idée reçue n'a rien inventé
le subaru une question que vous aimeriez
poser un jules verne pourquoi si peu de
femmes gentil ça existe jules les femmes
gentille qui êtes vous vraiment si jules
verne n'existait pas pour et en inventer
mais on en n'a pas réinventé depuis
jules verne
est irremplaçable si jules verne
existait pas
je me sentirai beaucoup beaucoup plus
petit merci messieurs avant de revenir
sur votre confrontation devrait
expliquer un petit peu le fonctionnement
cette jolie machine
celui qui parle peut être à tout moment
interrompues en tapant sur un de ces
boutons là d'accord alors avant ça je
voudrais roger midi vous dire que dans
ce que j'ai vu je ne retrouve pas le
côté un peu pugnace qu'on trouve dans
votre livre à savoir que jules verne
était un petit bourgeois étriqué mauvais
mari mauvais père antisémite anglophone
et il n'aurait pas écrit tous ses livres
alors j'aimerais j'aimerais que vous
commenciez et que vous défendiez ce
point de vue non je le vern a écrit
évidemment l'immense majorité de ces
livres bon à deux ou trois exceptions
près bon là eu des déceptions seulement
de trois exceptions c'est déjà pas mal
donc dos 3e faire scission de son
accession c'est quand même énervant 3
bon disons trois exceptions donc une de
ces exceptions c'est les 500 millions de
la bégum alors ça ça a été écrit au
départ par andré loris et son pseudonyme
se vend son vrai nom c'est pascal vous
c'est c'est un journaliste est un
communard c'est quelqu'un qui a été
exhibé en nouvelle calédonie qui sont
évadés avec rochefort et qui à londres
crevant de faim à contacter est elle en
lisant voilà moi j'ai des problèmes mais
je peux écrire et il a écrit les 500
millions de la bégum non pas comme un
head up c'est vrai je suis d'accord il
faut rendre hommage au maillot j'ai été
naïve
sans doute avez vous été [ __ ] et donc
il faut saluer ce monsieur donc il faut
saluer le [ __ ] je suis d'accord avec
vous pardon pour la confrontation donc
concilier ce que vous dites est passé là
où les loges du [ __ ] alors maintenant
on va bien sûr n'ont d'ailleurs un autre
point là votre temps de parole quand on
continue la cette histoire de
voeux de coups de pistolet sur le neveu
vous en parle et ça c'est très nébuleux
bon donc un jour de 1886 jules verne
ventes chez lui et là il se fait tirer
dessus à deux reprises une barre ce père
l'autre se loge dans son pied et il en
gardera des séquelles toute sa vie et le
tireur c'est son neveu son propre neveu
le bonhomme a été décrétée fou et encore
aujourd'hui personne mais personne ne
peut dire avec certitude ni quand il est
mort ue mais est-ce que ce neveu n'était
pas louis 17 oui parce que moi je me
disais ou le masque de fer au lieu de
faire c'est la norme et ce qui
m'intéresse beaucoup dans cette affaire
c'est votre votre passion pour aller
prendre les grands hommes et pour
trouver les petits côtés comme ça les
grands hommes et pour faire des grandes
oeuvres il faut peut-être petit sur des
grands partout il ya pas suffisamment
d'écart d'atmosphère ouest où est la
formule la formule est jolie
je vous remercie vous mais moi j'aime
bien l'adage qui aime bien châtie bien
et j'aime bien de savoir un petit peu
qui est qui alors est ce que vous aimez
jules oui oui oui j'aime jules verne bon
au départ ce bouquin devait s'appeler
biographie amoureuse bon sans parler des
femmes
on peut très bien avoir des hauts et des
bas avec son époux ce avec sa compagne
sans le lait de temps en temps se dire
ses quatre vérités
il a il a une maîtresse tendrement tv
d'un trait secours dit d'après ce qu'on
dit bon c'est là qu'à me lasser la
cabine à jules
la cabine à part que sa part que la
camille landais des photos pour rester à
l'as camilla de jeu où l'on n'a pas
grand chose on a des suppositions
vous ne soyez pas trop moraliste
l'adultère qui durent longtemps
ça vaut conjugalité non mais attire duré
longtemps on n'en sait rien à plusieurs
années et l'âge et des fiches
j'ai des fiches car j'ignorais que les
archives d'énergie du dix neuvième été
avec la démission 16 mais bien sûr
uniquement les archives amoureuse c'est
les seuls qui comptent c'est en effet
les plus intéressantes pour connaître
les hommes car beaucoup d'académiciens
sur des coquins
quel que soit l'âge quand vous ferez une
enquête sur nous méfier voilà et
l'antisémitisme de de jules verne
canetti qui répond avec le témoin je
vais commencer parce que c'est quelque
chose que qui m'intéresse beaucoup
jules verne était un homme dans son
assiette bon il faut pas voir
l'antisémitisme du dix neuvième siècle
comme on voit l'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui bon aujourd'hui il ya eu en
juillet il ya eu un verdict etc
on peut pas voir l'antisémitisme avec
les mêmes avec les yeux qu avait
quelqu'un de 1880 1870 et sur le plan c
est ce que vous êtes bien les il ya des
grands rôles en comme ça c'est vrai mais
se déroulant d'époque ce qu'ils sont des
relents d'époque et puis peut-être il
aurait pu être un peu plus un peu plus
un peu plus ouvert que d'autres plus
vilain regarder quand on prend quand on
prend hergé voilà vous prenez l'étoile
mystérieuse tous les méchants essaient
des savants juifs tout ça sans arrêt
donc il ya eu 7 se sait ce fond de l'air
terrifiant hook était lent tissier ça
nous empêche pas d'émerger vous l'avais
dit dans votre intention avec hergé
jules verne c'est le dix neuvième siècle
il est mort en 1905
hergé se sont antisémites et c'est un
antisémitisme qui s'est développée dans
les années 30 et qui a appris son apogée
dans les années 40 dans un journal
collaborateurs jules verne état
bourgeois catholique et rejette aussi à
montjoie cathodique
bon ben je joue seule loi bon mais très
influencé par les images de l'époque qui
était antisémite c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que cent ans après c'est encore
moins excusable
nasser je suis d'accord avec vous mais
globalement et ce qu'il faut lire vers
nous moi je le lis il n'y a pas de
raison que l'otan fasse pas autant et le
colonialisme dans tout ça à jules verne
sa position
personne n'en parle jules verne est un
écrivain de son temps à la france cette
époque là est un pays raciste en partie
c'est-à-dire qui donne qui ne reconnaît
pas les mêmes droits aux peuples
colonisés que mon français de souche
comme on dit maintenant
donc il est dans son temps bon il n'est
ni plus raciste noir à six canons sont
tous des traces dans l'oeuvre qui
pourrait bien sûr il ya des traces dans
l'oeil mais c'est d'abord un formidable
curieux c'est à dire il va au devant des
peuples c'est vrai ce qui est frappant
c'est qu'ils s'intéressent plus au
peuple comme sarr luxe contre une
oppression s'intéressent au peuple en
lutte contre une oppression candau
pression quand la lutte est terminée
depuis longtemps
on dit que jules verne la soupe du lay a
soutenu l'indépendance grecque pourquoi
il ya surtout la défense grecque les
graisses et exagère et est indépendant
depuis 50 ans on dit vrai c'est vrai
mais a le vrai que lors des jeux
mais non mais vous avez raison mais non
dits et non mais moi je parle des
classes sociales car c'est vrai qu'il
s'en fout complètement des dominés mais
quand même bon quand même bon jules
verne pour départ étant dit pas et
antidreyfusard il devient dreyfusards
quand pratiquement tout est terminé
c'est jules verne ou c'est son éditeur
qui est un formidable commerçants at
elle un sens de l'avant qui nous il ya
ce coup de génie est ce que votre
éditeur vrai sens du commerce joker
dites moi une question à voir qui va
vous agacer la la la fascination qu'ont
eue les nazis pour le personnage de les
mots qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire s'il
veut cesser dans vos livres c'est pour
ça c'est dans votre liste pour cette
chanson
il semblerait que goebbels se soit
intéressé à nemo pour en faire une sorte
de figure
le capitaine a three peat de notre
flotte de sous-marins eu beaucoup
ceci dit si dans 50 ans un dictateur en
france il s'intéresse au personnage le
rcena pour sa propagande c'est pas la
faute de main sur senna est d'ailleurs
monsieur sénat va conclure parce que ça
orsenna est en retard et bien memory dit
qu'il aime la mer je pense pas qu'ils
énormément de mythologie de la mer dans
le nazisme
il aime la liberté on peut pas dire
qu'ils aient beaucoup de liberté dans le
nazisme
donc c'est extraordinaire de faire
porter comme ça à jules verne ce genre
de pêcher aussi aussi terrible non ça
c'est une bêtise
permettez-moi de boules de glace et on
terminera sur sur cette bêtise et moi je
suis très content et même de vous avoir
un petit peu titillé parce que je crois
qu en vous écoutant on a maintenant que
de bonnes raisons et d'aimer jules verne
messieurs au terme cette confrontation
comme on le faisait je vous demanderai
de vous serrer la main
quand je sais pas
tu sais ce qu'on dit on et les grands
écrivains appartiennent à tous les chefs
d'oeuvre à chacun ça fait un petit peu
pompeux comme ça mais c'est ce qui nous
intéresse ici
doit on voudrait montrer comment un
livre peut être important pour quelqu'un
à la place qu'il a qui l'a pris pour lui
et soir justement andré à coolio nous
parle de la métamorphose des capteurs un
chef-d'oeuvre tu connais tu te rappelles
l'histoire de deux stops
c'est assez incroyable ça fait peur et
qui se retrouve transformé en cafard
bien elle est l'aînée dans le corps d'un
homme ce qui lui correspondait
absolument pas elle a voulu devenir une
femme donc elle a entrepris toi ça sa
propre métamorphose pour devenir la
femme qu'elle est aujourd'hui à celle
qu'on vend celle qu'on va voir et qui
nous raconte l'histoire de la
métamorphose de kafka comment elle a
vécu elle et comment elle a retrouvé son
histoire dans la métamorphose de kafka
d'avoir c'est un document assez
saisissant en tout cas moins que moi qui
m'a dit m'a troublé et ça prouve que tu
vois il faut toujours revenir
prochainement
un matin au sortir d'un rêve agitée
gregor samsa s'éveilla transformé dans
son lit en un énorme cancrelats
le 12 avril 2001 le steward bruno coolio
devient l'hôtesse andrea qu'au lieu
la métamorphose de gregor se fait en une
nuit d'été qui se réveille le matin et
les conscient pour lui toutes les choses
semblent normales
jusqu'au moment où il veut descendre son
lit est là et prend conscience qu'il
peut pas
il devient un cafard ma métamorphose à
moi elle est étalée dans le temps sur 10
ans très exactement
il était couché sur le dos indo dur
comme une cuirasse il s'aperçut qu'il
avait un ventre blanc en forme de voûte
/ des nervures arqués
sur certains points je dirais que la
métamorphose andrea a été similaire à la
métamorphose de kafka
déjà il ya un rejet de la masculinité je
vivais dans un état d'une personne qui
n'est pas dans le corps dans lequel elle
devait se trouver
il y avait aussi l'isolément qui est
très présent dans le livre puisqu'il ne
sort jamais ta chambre en fait sauf une
fois et on le renvoie très vite de
l'année
[Musique]
il s'aperçut que son aspect n'avait pas
cessé d'inspirer de la répugnance à sa
soeur qu'il en sera toujours ainsi
grigor lui subi l'exclusion a bâti
moment il se transforme
moi je les ai vécu avant pendant après
[Musique]
au regard de la société je ne serai
jamais une femme biologique
andrea sera toujours pour résumer un le
steward qui est devenue une hôtesse de
l'air alors que pour gregor
c'est dans le non dit il est laid il est
2 et donc on le rejette
[Musique]
son fils malgré sa triste et répugnante
métamorphose landver est pas moins un
membre de la famille
gregor il se réveille il est plus gregor
sauf dans sa tête
andrea elle se réveille le 12 avril 2001
dans l'après midi elle n'est pas encore
rentré à ce qu officiellement elle
s'appelle encore bruno mais son corps
n'est plus le même son corps entre
guillemets d'hommes qui avait déjà
beaucoup de prédisposition à devenir un
corps de femme est devenue un corps de
femme je dirais peut-être à 200% parce
qu'il est il est tellement parfait que
quelque part il peut en devenir suspect
alors que grigor va perdre ses sens mais
six ans d'être humain c'est-à-dire la
faculté de se comporter comme un être
humain pour au contraire se comporter
comme un animal d'ailleurs au bout d'un
moment on décrira la pièce dans laquelle
il vit comme un te dit quelque chose
d'immonde qu'il dut partir ils le
savaient et son opinion sur ce point
était encore plus arrêter s'il est
possible
que c'est le même de sa soeur
les volumes gregor dans une société qui
dictent normalisé dont le père est
synonyme de virilité donc garant de
l'image de la famille et donc de la
procréation et de la société pour se
déculpabiliser peut-être ou pour se
dédouaner du fardeau il représente pour
cette société ce huis clos
il choisit la mort vous faites andrea a
commencé à vivre le jour où bruno est
mort bruno choisi de mourir entre
guillemets pour laisser naître
andrea pour que enfin
elles puissent évoluer dans une pseudo
normalité
elle cria fortement ses mots dans
l'obscurité venez donc voir il est crevé
il est là les coucher par terre il est
crevé comme un rat
si j'avais pas pu évoluer par rapport à
ce que j'étais ce que j'étais un vilain
scarabée 1 l'issue aurait été la même
mais contrairement à gregor j'ai choisi
de ne pas aller vers une issue aussi
fatale mais vers un épanouissement
donc c'est là toute la différence l'un
meurt dans son état de négation totale
alors que l'autre renaît dans un ehpad
de 2,2 de chrysalide qui tend à devenir
un papillon
quand un ouvrage sort la critique sont
en parle c'est la règle du jeu et que la
critique soit bonne ou qu'elle soit
mauvaise l'auteur n'y plus rien on peut
rien dire
il peut rien faire pourtant on est bien
des manger parfois alors dans cette
rubrique ping pong on donne l'occasion à
un auteur de répondre à une critique
plutôt sévère sur le dernier ouvrage qui
vient de sortir
alors côté pile j'allais dire le jean
christophe rufin le french doctor des
lettres françaises comme on l'appelle
qui avec l'abyssin a fait un succès
énorme en 97 et qui a obtenu le prix
goncourt avec rouge brésil et qui sort
un un nouveau roman qui se passe au
brésil la salle amende alors la
salamandre on peut dire que c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune française de 46
ans et catherine qui va vivre un dernier
amour tumultueux et tragique au brésil
pendant les vacances alors ce brésil ses
vacances cet amour ça fait un peu roman
sea sex and sun c'est ce que dit un peu
jean luisi alors on va vous confronter à
jean louis ezine mais avant jean
chrisophe franchement comment tu reçois
les critiques d'habitude belle et vraie
critique sur les critiques de gens qui
se sont penchés sur votre texte est fait
qu'il en lui vraiment moi je les reçois
bien c'est à dire que je trouve que pour
un auteur faut tenir compte de ce
commence de ce qu'on vous dit un truc
aventure quand tu reçois une critique
très détaillé moi j'en tiens compte
simplement
ça dépend des critiques c'est à dire
qu'il ya des gens qui font pas leur
boulot c'est autre chose
tu dois connaître ça il ya des gens qui
quittent pour suivre tu sais pas
pourquoi
miles in il a toujours critiqué tous mes
beaux cas tous donc ça un harceleur
ouais enfin il ya quelque chose qui va
pas quoi avec ma gueule c'est pas
quelque chose qui lui revient pas c'est
évident mais bon t'as eu des prix les
grands prix c'est ce que c'est
on sait qu'on est des cibles alors on va
voir un peu le détail et puis tu vas le
l'occasion n'hésite pas d'abord jean
christophe rufin je dirais est un
écrivain sans écriture déjà saturé avons
déjà comment se force à commencer par et
alors mais c'est marrant parce que
toulon en photo toute sa critique c'est
ça sur des trucs idiots tu pour un
bouquin je ne lis pas mais tu dis
franchement tu penses que les inapte à
lui franchement ça pourrait paraître
rédhibitoire mais ça ne l'est pas
nécessairement il n'y a pas que des
écrivains d'écriture je veux dire qu'ils
sont des écrivains de crime à qui vous
savez qu'ils ont ce génie de vous faire
partager une émotion un crime à une cool
on ne sait pas faire ça tous ceux qui
s'appuie beaucoup sur le style je pense
que lui c'est plutôt un conteur tint bon
raconteur d'histoires c'est un bon
manufacturier
nettoyer sa grâce à toi oui alors ça
c'est moi c'est un compliment ça un bon
manufacturier c'est un compliment parce
que moi je me suis jamais pris pour un
autre
comme disait canadien je ne prends pas
pour un écrivain quand on dit je raconte
bien des histoires ça me va ça me va
simplement il ya un truc c'est que ya
une contradiction entre les deux c'est à
dire que tu peux pas raconter des
histoires sans avoir un style c'est à
dire que chaque histoire
moi j'admire journaux pourquoi parce que
chaque histoire il te la raconter avec
un style riddick j'ai pas de style
anglais ni combien l'histoire s'attarde
d'ailleurs il a eu le prix d'entrée peut
pas être un hasard quand même ça c'est
pas précisé c'est latina chatel renault
dopage était passée dans la rue où s'est
comporté en métal par hasard chez jean
paul dispard intitulé rouge brésil
hélas hélas c'est la deuxième fois qu'il
évoque je crois le brésil dans un roman
et ça tombe bien parce que c'est l'année
du brésil donc on est on a du brésil à
toutes les sauces l'aspect très
opportuniste alors ça c'est bon parce
que dans dans l'arctique si tu veux en
gros il peut il le dit beaucoup plus
clairement que la la il prend des gants
quand même il est bon c'était l'année du
brésil il savait pas quoi faire ils
sortis à lécher le brésil or monsieur en
2001 pour moi j'ai vécu au brésil je
parle portugais aussi parfois qui guette
garçons mais de 10 rebonds
l'investissement affectif dans ce pays
depuis très longtemps tu vois l'idée de
se dire j'ai un peu insultant ça doit
l'idée de se dire à l'année du brésil je
vais te fais un petit livre ce loisir
les prochaines c'est parce que c'est
serré des baleines sont pas ou je sais
pas quoi faire aller très bon tu vois
c'est un peu enfin le drame c'est qu'il
a oublié son talent de raconteur même le
brésil qu'il nous montre là c'est un
brésil de pacotille sens
lens c'est un vrai chrome os à mai
c'est insupportable à cause de ça alors
ça c'est très intéressant parce que cela
peut parler de minutes du livre si tu
veux le principe du livre c'est une
femme qui part au président pourquoi el
para brésil parce qu'elle est en
vacances donc elle voit tout le début du
livre est assez assez plat je suis
d'accord il est assez plat parce qu'elle
est dans le brésil exotiques les dents
elle a regardé les catalogues et puis
elle va elle va là et puis en effet elle
pense tout ça et puis les la copine chez
qui elle tend à lui elle lui donne cette
image du brésil et ça ça prouve
absolument sûr qu'il a pas eu beaucoup
parce que ça c'est le début du livre
c'est le premier chapitre dont il a
voulu faire grâce pense qu'il a lu pour
l'échappée pas mal mais ce qu'il dit là
ne s'applique qu'à ça c'est à dire que
tout le livre c'est justement le livre
de quelqu'un qui connaît un pays
ce que je dis pas que je connais
parfaitement le brésil mais j'ai quand
même vécu et tout ce qu'on y trouve
c'est l'envers du pays d'autres situés à
dire 5 romo s'est complètement
53 centièmes plus qu'un composant cesser
la production du fait que nos épaules et
donc
ce roman lavaud si j'ose dire
il ne vaut rien mais s'il devait valoir
quand même pas laisser passer
sinon même s'ils font certainement
facile la pauvreté du style propre
étonnement mais surtout la pauvreté du
décor et de l'intriguent je dirais que
c'est écrivain là à l'air de
complètement haïr son personnage ou le
détester en tout cas il n'a pas mis
l'île au dieu parce que c'est quand tu
ressens les choses c'est intéressant
parce que si tu veux il se vante t il
quand il va masque et la plume et tous
que il pas rebondir les bouquins moi je
j'ai fait des trucs en radio et où il
disait vous faites des trop gros livre
moi je les dis pas que c'était un jeudi
je pense aussi aux gens qui aiment uncam
ce que je voyais à la 1100 milles
personnes qui ont acheté leur rôle
brésil je dirais qu'il en est mais alors
alors craché à la gueule cox alors
explique code c'est un style de merde et
que ça n'a aucun intérêt
je trouve que c'est pas très respectueux
pour les lecteurs mais ce que tu penses
à tout électeur est ce que c'est
vraiment ça non non non non vous ne peut
avoir de pitié par exemple il a même pas
de pitié pour ce personnage qui nous
expose sous des dehors qui sont
systématiquement et exclusivement
physiologique et je crois que c'est un
ancien médecin dieu ça tu pâti du fait
que tu as et médecins pour lui chacun
bien de son horizon ma le mien ses semis
médecine et c'est vrai que ma pendant
des années j'ai bossé s'engager oui mais
je veux dire j'ai surtout j'ai
énormément lutter pour sortir je garde
la fatalité où j'étais à cause de la
médecine où on me disait vous êtes à
manuellement vous pas un intellectuel
pour devenir un écrivain
j'ai dû remonter le courant ce que j'ai
dû sortir de ça de ce mépris et depuis
tout ce que j'ai vécu dans les manières
de ce que j'ai vécu
les portraits les paysages des couleurs
tout ça c'est ça qui fait mes livres
donc si tu veux non mais simplement
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
est difficile à mesurer les gens
beaucoup de respect pour les médecins
mais on leur donne des limites
et quand il touche des trucs qui les
regardent pas dans les relais mais quand
même on y croit on y croit jamais on est
malheureux même on est malheureux pour
cette femme
catherine à qui il arrive les pires
turpitudes dans son roman mais
je dirais que en dehors des turpitudes
qui tiennent à coeur et sa raison des
turpitudes ça évite d'avoir à résumé
l'attaquant la panacée mais c'est
embêtant
il ya surtout la turpitude d'être
manipulé par un écrivain qui n'y croit
pas du tout mais c'est pour ça que je
sens oui alors venez québec est libre
pas je veux dire je suis désolé moi
cette histoire justement je vais apprise
ya 12 ans m'a raconté cette histoire
c'est une histoire toute bête hein c'est
l'histoire d'une femme qui part en
vacances au brésil et qui reste et qui
ne reviendra pas et qui va aller
jusqu'au bout d'une passion je raconte
pas le détail de la chose mais ce qui
est authentique cette histoire moi elle
m'a habité pendant 12 ans on doit donc
voilà senna ou là où la critique devrait
trouver est un petit peu plus prudente
et les critiques se rendent pas compte
souvent qui touche quand même une
matière assez sensible des roannais et
voilà on est on est créé et nommé tôt
visa série tribun
nos vives j'ai le sentiment que ce
rendement est un pur désastre voilà ce
que tu te sens mieux après sa petite tu
sais je ne cherche pas chez moi j'ai pas
des réactions comme ça j'ai plutôt
direction de
je sais pas tu connais tu as eu aussi je
vais dire tous les écrivains ils ont
peut-être cru assez dit [ __ ] ge energy
voilà j'ai fait quelque chose de bon
j'ai fait ce que je pouvais faire de
mieux
peut-être qu'on peut le faire mieux mais
moi je pouvais pas et st gall se dire ou
même pas le truc et puis te crache
dessus c'est un peu dommage mais est ce
que tu penses que c'est utile en mars
après 913 utilitaire que son qu'il doit
y avoir des relations de respect entre
les critiques et les auteurs moi je
respecte des critiques je vraiment je
les respecte et je reçois parfois enfin
pour certains des livres des critiques
maixent dur mais qui sont extrêmement
détaillée des gens qui te dit qu'ils
écrivent dans des journaux ailleurs
voilà telle partie des personnages telle
chose n'est pas bonne et sage prouve que
même si c'est parfois dur entendre
parfois on te dit même c'est carrément
loupé moi je sais que yann mes bouquins
par exemple je sais qu'il est il est
loupé je veux dire la suite de l'absence
des loupés geler la critique me l'a dit
je n'ai entendu j'ai compris et donc le
critique moi je le respecte mais faut
que j'y vais ce minimum de respect qui
consiste quand même à nous lire bon bah
j'espère que on aura bien compris ça
enfin jour que ça que moi je voulais te
remercier parce que c'est pas un
exercice facile est à tu as accepté de
le faire et ça j'en suis moins 128
remercié parce que du monde m17
[Musique]
qui n'a jamais rêvé de se glisser dans
l'intimité d'un écrivain d'être une
petite souris au mieux une caméra vidéo
frédéric beigbeder a décidé de jouer le
jeu pour nous dans ce journal intime il
traite de ses thèmes de prédilection qui
sont on les connaît la fin du monde
le succès l'insatisfaction son frigo
ces médicaments est lui bien sûr
toujours lui les thèmes que l'on
retrouve dans son dernier roman paru
chez grasset l'égoïste romantique ou
oscar dufresne et le héros et beigbeder
le narrateur
à moins que ce ne soit à linverse avec
frédéric on ne sait jamais mais vous
allez voir dans ce journal intime
frédéric est touchant et c'est un sacré
généreux c'est égoïste
là on est chez moi je suis frédéric
beigbeder ah non pas lui
et alors ça c'est tout le sujet de mon
dernier livre l'égoïste romantique chez
comment échapper à frédéric bébé j'ai
trouvé une solution
le roman c'est vachement pratique le
roman parce qu'on est libre on peut dire
des trucs qu'on a vraiment fait des
trucs qu'on n'a pas vraiment fait des
trucs qui nous ressemblent des trucs qui
ne ressemble pas mais qu'on pense encore
plus que les trucs pensé par celui qui
nous ressemble
enfin bref ça a été inventé pour ça la
technique consiste simplement à écrire
son journal en changeant le nom
principal le côté julien gracq et un
proche
nature quand quand je suis attaqué
critiquer j'ai l'impression que c'est
que c'est la personne qui dit ça qui as
raison tu persuadé si on me dit que mon
livre elle revêt que mon livre est
mauvaise que la personne a raison qui
que ce soit il faut que j'arrête tout
thoune a tout ce que j'ai fait depuis
toujours n'a aucun intérêt que je n'ai
aucun intérêt
voilà ça c'est ma chambre je n'ai plus
du tout du tout dit privé à partir de
cette émission ce que je fais c'est
quand j'ai du mal à m'endormir le soir
je prends des manuscrits
c'est un avantage d'être éditeur on peut
assez rapidement avoir sommeil c'est un
métier très chiant puis comme tous les
métiers que j'ai fait mais qui a
davantage de de créer de vraies
rencontres
je progresse dans la mesure où j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une qualité de
rencontres humaines supérieur est ce que
ça pouvait être ya encore trois quatre
ans j'essaie d'aller au musée rodin plus
souvent au lieu d'aller chez castel
alors ça c'est vraiment un ordinateur où
j'écris l'égoïste romantique c'est une
chanson donc je cite un livre il se dit
end of the world as we feel fine une
chanson du groupe et rer
et je pense que c'est un des meilleurs
slogans de
actuel tu vois c'est la fin du monde est
le sens quelle erreur
c'est l'apocalypse
nous sommes en train de s'autodétruire
le chanteur explique sam et qui sont
très très bien ça résume assez bien
moment là
j'ai une vie qui me correspond à sa main
lider je réussis sociale voilà au fola
au matériel ça ne rend pas heureux je
trouve ça plus intéressant que quelqu'un
qui dirait c'est génial j'ai grosses
voitures jamais la parte c'est
magnifique
non moi je pense que l'on peut être
compliqué torturé bizarre dire un truc
et faire l'un vers fait un truc et dire
linverse et faire ça toute sa vie
je pense que ça pose aucun problème et
c'est le grand confort d'être un
romancier c'est de pouvoir justement
être totalement incohérent cohérent
absurde se plaindre dans des boîtes de
nuit de luxe il des boîtes de nuit de
luxe
ça c'est la liste des médicaments
empêchant qu'elles survivent
l'impression de près de préférer la
petite musique là grâce là le mystère le
charme plutôt de chekhov le bolchoï
plutôt plutôt fédéral que anyway et puis
en france
ouais c'est pas plus de cinq ans que
proust un frigo il y avait plein de
produits il ya un peu plus et que ça
c'est dit
évidemment ça sa décla morize un peu le
personnage mais pourquoi pas ici
ciao
[Musique]
où
oh
e
souvenez vous dans les années 60 le
dramaturge polonais witold gombrowicz
avait fait le pari d'apprendre la
philosophie à sa femme rita en 6h15 ce
soir virginie despentes relève le défi
et se propose de nous parler de
dostoïevski en six minutes 15 secondes
alors vous me direz quel rapport entre
l'auteur de baise-moi ce livre sorti en
1993 et dont le film frise à
l'interdiction en 2000 et dostoïevski
l'écrivain du péché et de la rédemption
et bien la passion la passion qu à
virginie despentes pour l'univers de
l'auteur déposséder pour ces fanatiques
ces paumés pour ces [ __ ] c'est ce dont
on va nous parler ce soir virginie
despentes donc en quoi deux téléskis ça
peu avant le moindre rapport avec ce que
je fais comme vous l'avez dit c'est dû à
l'écrivain effectivement de la
rédemption du péché d'adoption mais
c'est aussi effectivement d'écrivains
qui fait des portraits buts
extraordinaires notamment dans l'idiot
dans les carnets du sous-sol des dépôts
retraits de fille perdue que des héros
vont essayer de remettre pas l'endroit
semaine dans une sorte de bonheur à
chaque mois s'est lamentablement mal se
passer au bhoutan un équipement mal se
passer
il ya plusieurs théories sur la question
aujourd'hui quand on lit les lieux
graphique de ce kiosque et quand on dit
deux sources qui avec leurs gardes
comptant pour un combat on pense
forcément à l'inceste médias c est ce qu
il ya un père qui un médecin qui est un
ivrogne qui tape sa ferme ça c'est connu
a priori on peut on peut imaginer
vraiment qu'il y avait un 16 sur moi sur
la petite soeur qui était donc la soeur
de ce thème serait donc il a deux
témoins duquel ils auraient été témoins
et qu'il a prévenu qu empêcher ou quoi
que ce soit et ça va vraiment rester
chez lui un thème récurrent et lui en
tant qu'agresseur et lui en tant qu
incapable de défendre une jeune fille
est aussi donc le thème de la femme
du qui va traiter comme personne d'autre
fois le père du dossier ce qui
d'ailleurs ne meurt assassiné quand
dassier qui a 18 ans il assassiné par
des serres il est assassiné à coups de
pierres et de talent sont secs s'est
écrasé à klépierre ont compté images
nexen par chance après un violent encore
quoi et la soeur de celle ci sa seule
réaction quand elle apprend l'assassinât
de son père c'est pour un chien une mort
de chien donc on en imagine vraiment
c'est pas effectivement ce drame du père
qui est un père maltraitant qui est un
père incapable qui est un père
respectable seulement à l'extérieur de
la maison et pas une toile à la maison
c'est un thème vachement contemporain et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles de
ces skis aujourd'hui ça semble
complètement évident la même façon et
parle d'une russie où tout le monde
cherche et d'utopie tout le monde
cherche à à croire en des choses et les
gens semblent sans fin pour un tas de
choses et le paye dans le réel à ses
diamants et pm façon ça nous renvoie
vraiment une époque et à une société
malheureusement une europe qui est un
peu con bien docile à l'époque c'est à
dire en complète déliquescence et pas
des façons baisser mois dernier aussi
c'est moderne parce que il n'ya que des
dialogues et c'est un choix qui fait
c'est un choix stylistiques de 17 ce qui
reste manque de dialogue a plus aucune
description donc à l'époque c'est
étonnant mais aujourd'hui c'est tout
simplement extrêmement cinématographique
donc c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles la lecture de celle ci est
vachement
facile est évidente et semble
extrêmement contemporaine et enfin
d'ostéo ce qui s'est vraiment il va se
mettre à parler du peuple mais du peuple
du peuple des cafards et vraiment de
l'intérieur une des raisons pour
lesquelles des chefs qui connaît bien le
peuple à part qu'ils ont assassiné son
père c'est aussi que lui va faire dix
ans de banny l'albanie va être un
intellectuel chez les ch et les serres
donc le roman social en russie tout le
monde en écrit l'élu pour le coup il va
être pratiquée le peuple il va se rendre
compte à quel point le peuple ne pas
abîmer donc c'est vraiment une vision à
la fois sociales progressistes utopiste
la photo il y connaît bien de problèmes
et à quel point le peuple veut pas
prendre le pas de la révolution ces
choses que lui connaît vraiment en dix
ans de bagne il a le temps de comprendre
ce genre de choses mais du coup il parle
quand il va se mettre à parler à la
place des petites gens ils parlent
vraiment comme les petites gens avec et
pas seulement comme un fantasme petites
gens de susciter quelques apprendre
qu'ils adoraient dickens genre de sang
des jeunes suis peut-être plus que ces
gens là il est pour le meilleur et pour
le pire il aura vraiment côtoyé jean je
voulais lire le début des carnets du
sous sol qui a un peu de ceci à
plusieurs époques dans sa ville un
succès de terreur quand il est jeune
mais après cette histoire d'evine
pendant dix ans et puis après revient il
aimait beaucoup beaucoup de temps avant
de devenir un auteur qui compte pour la
critiquer pour les autres publics est un
des livres par lesquels il revient c'est
l'écart des du sous sol qui est vraiment
un livre éminemment contemporain que les
au début bien sûr voilà je suis un homme
malade je suis un homme méchant un homme
repoussoir voilà ce que si je crois que
j'ai quelque chose au foie de toute
façon ma maladie qui n'y comprend rien
j'ignore au juste ce qui me fait mal je
ne me soigne pas je ne me suis jamais
soigné
même si je respecte la médecine et les
docteurs en plus je suis superstitieux
comme ce n'est pas permis
enfin assez pour respecter la médecine
je suis suffisamment instruits pour né
pas être superstitieux mais je suis
superstitieux quand même oui c'est par
méchanceté que je ne me soigne pas ça
messieurs je parie que c'est une chose
que vous ne comprenez pas mois ci est
cependant messieurs savez vous ce qui
surtout faisait le fondement méchanceté
c'est là qu'était le de la faire c'est
là qu'était la saleté la plus
nauséabonde qu'à chaque instant même
dans les montées de bill les plus
irrépressible je comprenais honteusement
que non seulement je n'étais pas un
homme
méchant je n'étais même pas aigri je le
passais mon temps qu'à faire peur aux
moineaux et je trouvais là toute ma
satisfaction
j'avais vécu aux lèvres mais il m'aurait
suffi qu'on m'apporte une poupée qu'on
me donne du thé avec du sucre
je me serais radouci j'vous jure même
l'émotion me reste serré la gorge après
sans doute aurais-je grincer des dents
contre moi-même de honte et j'aurais eu
des insomnies pendant des mois je suis
comme ça vient gêner la lumière vient de
s'éteindre
on va faire semblant de croire que c'est
l'esprit de dostoïevski qui a écrit deux
souterrains qui nous fait un petit clin
d'oeil et qui vous remercie et on y va
m
oh
non
[Applaudissements]
on dit que l'écrivain utilise plusieurs
masques calixthe belaya le sait bien
elle enfante douala qui a choisi une
héroïne blanche pour raconter l'histoire
de son dernier roman la plantation une
sorte d' autant en emporte le vent dans
le zimbabwe d'aujourd'hui dans cette
caméra cachée et kalix a choisi de
changer complètement
d'apparence à l'est devenu espèce de
d'employés tyrannisé par beyala alors
moi calix tyrannisé par beyala j'ai
envie de voir ça
e
bonjour je suis calixthe beyala tout à
l'heure je vous allez me voir jouer mon
rôle qui consiste à vendre les livres de
la méchante calixthe beyala en tant
qu'employé on va voir comment les gens
réagissent aussi groupe cette histoire
ou pas bonjour juste moi je suis chargé
de faire la promotion de ses livres
jeudi l'auteur rend jalouse alors qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
je sais bien
[Musique]
je sais pas si c'est lui paiera jusqu'à
pour moi
mais franchement je vous le conseille à
la plantation parce que c'est vraiment
bien écrit c'est vraiment une très belle
histoire de ces familles qui sont des
familles blanches mais en fait qu'ils
sont des des africains qu'on chasse
aujourd'hui d'afrique et que nous te
penses qu'il était normal de chercher
les gens d'un pays tout simplement en
fonction de leur couleur c'est pas vrai
comme précis et les êtres humains sont
plus de leur culture que de leur vie la
race
ça prouve vraiment plaire à la personne
que vous connaissez cette hauteur
elle m'a chargé l'auteur de faire la
promotion de ses livres
ça vous plaît que je vous pose en saxe
pourquoi vous l'auteur non pourquoi pas
je sais pas je sais tout
bah oui mais elle est devenue très
business woman parce qu'elle trouve que
aujourd'hui les auteurs américains
occupent trop de place parce qu'il faut
vraiment du marketing et que les auteurs
français sur un pur ailier au second
rang ils n'en font pas donc elle m'a
chargé présenter le livre aux lecteurs
qui veulent bien
bonjour monsieur mais je suis là pour
faire la promotion d'un livre s'est
chargé de vous parler le summum en la
plantation qui raconte une histoire des
familles blanches installées en rhodésie
depuis deux siècles et qu'on vient de
chasser finalement du zimbabwe l'avons
entendu par les axes histoire est une
histoire vraie à la base
parce que j'habite en
on y est
ah oui il faut vraiment le problème
parce que sinon je vais me faire virer
par m e tron
vous voulez je vous en fais cadeau aussi
prête à tout vous savez et aimez partent
avec mais en tout cas ne les ai pas
comme ça non non non
si vous voulez vous voulez vous c'est un
coût de ce roman s'il vous plaît oh
merci bien ça vous intéresse vivre quand
même l'impression vous connaissez
l'afrique génifique amoureuses d'accord
dans cette ville une africain gens quand
vous parlez d'une
ses cheveux d'or et son cas parce que
les melons dans lequel je pense que
c'est laid ce raid pour elle c'est
amusant parce que c'est le livre que
j'ai oublié en bretagne que j'ai pas
terminée là donc je tiens celui ci
jusqu'à livres 2 qu'une aiguille alors
[Musique]
vous allez me dire ce soir on ne voit
que des écrivains confirmés des vieux
routier des plateaux télé mais alors où
est la relève
où sont les jeunes pousses et bien vous
allez découvrir ce soir
mon père est un petit big au premier
roman de sonia moumen sommes nous-mêmes
bonsoir alors d'abord on va vous poser
la question traditionnelle
est ce que c'est bien votre première
télé c'est bien ma première vivant alors
on va continuer l'exploration
biographique
alors vous avez 35 ans vous êtes né à
annecy de père algérien et de mère pieds
noirs au maroc et vous avez un fils
vous avez un fils alors il s'appelle
millan amour qui veut dire lumière en
arabe et babar alors j'avoue que ça m'a
surpris par qu'est ce que ça veut dire
comment on peut prénommé son fils bart
apparemment on peut laisser quand même
babar dirige quand même un royaume très
important qui suivent l'enfance et des
éléphants
le petit garçon aussi sur le roi du
royaume on peut le dire c'est l'histoire
d'une jeune femme qui se raconte à 3 à
travers trois hommes son père son amant
et son fils dont on vient de parler mais
est cette femme
franchement c'est vous c'est un peu
moins mais pas complètement mais si
c'est quand même beaucoup oui on croit
on croit vraiment que tout est
autobiographique quand on le lit alors
il reste encore alors j'ai commencé
quand même par quelque chose qui est
assez saisissant le titre mon père est
un petit big o j'ai envie de vous
demander sonia moumen
qu'est ce qu'il en a pensé votre permis
ce titre ça l'à beaucoup amusé lui qui a
cherché pendant des années des années à
camoufler ses origines et qui vous a
toujours soutenu qu'il n'était pas déjà
rien mes pieds noirs qui nous a jamais
parlé arabe qui n'a jamais failli à
renier sa religion
je crois que ça l'a beaucoup amusée que
par un pied de nez on clame haut et fort
finalement qu'il est bien un petit big o
oui alors baisser quand même un petit
big aux particuliers dont vous êtes très
très fier parce que votre père
c'était aussi un amoureux des mots un
fou de dictionnaires par exemple alors
je pense que c'est lui qui vous a
transmis
c'est cet amour de la langue je crois
que c'est effectivement lui
mon père quand il est arrivé en france
en a besoin de s'intégrer son
intégration est passé entre autres par
un apprentissage forcené de la langue
française et une maîtrise impressionnant
pour mon père parmi nos français mais la
voilà cette formule que vous utilisez
souvent dans le texte avec un niveau de
langage impressionnant il nous a
assommés pendant toute notre enfance
avec l'étymologie des mots avec les
citations avec les synonymes
aujourd'hui je crois que je lui dois
la richesse de vocabulaire jeu alors
deux deuxièmes j'allais dire deuxième
volet l'amant cet amant aux cheveux gris
cet amant plus âgée que vous une espèce
de découverte la plénitude et de
sensualité
oui complètement un homme formidable
d'ailleurs cette partie s'appelle mon
amant et un homme formidable
j'ai eu envie à travers cette deuxième
partie de rendre hommage tout simplement
à l'amour et à la passion amoureuse tout
en introduisant beaucoup d'ironie et
c'est vrai que ma maman il ya des
cheveux gris
il m'est jamais richard les courses au
supermarché il ne sait pas faire de
barbecue et cumule les handicaps
finalement et finalement ça même quand
même formidable c'est un bricoleur
velléitaire commence tout juste à sortir
les outils ne se passe jamais rien c'est
ça complètement complètement et en même
temps
c'est un c'est un homme tout simplement
avec ses faiblesses aussi et c'est ce
qui m'a intéressé aussi à travers ce
livre c'est de montrer la faiblesse de
ses différents semble montrer que c'est
cette faiblesse qu'il ait grandi finale
mais parce qu'il ya un grand amour pour
lui pour lui pour son corps parce que
c'est un livre qui est extrêmement
sensuelle et vous parlez très très
directement de son corps et de ses
formes de ces odeurs mêmes
je viens d'une famille les choses du
corps sont dit de manière assez crue les
choses du sexe aussi sont finalement
assez cru qu'il faut souvent l'objet de
débats nabeul par exemple la main sur la
terminologie est une hérésie
c'est à dire que on voit tout au long du
livre qu'une petite fille
son trésor c'est d'avoir des fresques
bien pommelé que quand elles rentrent au
bled si elle en a pas on se demande ce
que va en faire d'où mon grand
désagrément quand j'étais adolescente
près de descente puisque je n'avais pas
de fesses rebondies et donc je n'étais
pas un objet
depuis je me suis largement rattrapé mai
en tous les cas oui la sensualité fait
partie pour moi du quotidien de la vie
de la vie amoureuse mais aussi de la vie
qui courent et j'ai essayé de
transmettre ça aussi par le langage vous
n'aimeriez pas qu'on dise sonia moumen
écrivent un écrivain beurette absolument
pas je sais qu'on va aussi si l'on
classé dans la catégorie de la
bourgeoise c'est très peu
d'abord je ne suis pas peur et par
ailleurs je ne suis pas vous rejoins
donc je refuse d'entrer dans cette
catégorie qu'on puisse aussi mon côté
rebelle j'ai pas envie qu'on met dans
une case
je voudrais vous faire lire ou vous
demander de lire un extrait des mille et
une nuits chedhomme de la littérature
arabe et d'être un peu ce soir qui vient
qui vient de sortir
c'est une édition plaisir était très
belle et qui est qui vient justement de
sortir et j'aimerais que vous soyez ce
soir notre sherazade utilisait un pass
allait bien sûr j'ai choisi un passage
qui rend compte de toute sensualité
qu'on trouve dans votre texte vous
écoute d'un clin d'oeil elle renvoyait à
ces survivants ses suivantes pardon on
reprend en gros d'un clin d'oeil elle
renvoyait à ses suivantes 20 mois et
m'en lasse à nous nous embrasse à pleine
bouche
elle me suisse à la lèvre supérieure je
lui sucer la lèvre inférieure bientôt
mes mains descendirent vers ses hanches
je lui fis un clin d'oeil nous abat team
sur le sol elle des graphes à son
sarouel je m'engageais entre ses jambes
ou aux chevilles cercle edano ce ne fut
plus que caresse l'accolade innodry
étendre propre aux morsures et
engendrement poursuite aux quatre coins
enfin rompu épuisée elle s'abandonne à
une voluptueuse un souci inconscience
voilà on vous remercie en vous remercie
et moi je suis certain je peux vous le
dire que ça n'est pas votre dernière
télévision en tous cas merci c'est bien
merci à vous
[Musique]
excusez moi nous avons fermé maintenant
tout de suite là
c'est là encore un peu ton nom mais ce
fêtard mais on sait leur tape à passer
une bonne soirée c'était pas si c'est
très très très bonne soirée
mais bon je vais dire ça guerre mais la
soirée tira sa part eux et je comprends
je comprends pas les matches que ses
gardes on va
on va y aller pour accompagner et on
revient espère j'espère sa compagne tu
vois je lançais aller
stress intense et très très bonne
ambiance
merci à vous bonne soirée sera au revoir
[Musique]
oh